have you stolen any props from the sets
of your movies
yep i have a hammer from just about
every film i think and they're all
scattered around the house in various
places they often end up in the
in the toilet
[Music]
who is the funniest co-star you've ever
worked with yes chris pratt's hilarious
down he's obviously hilarious um and
mark ruffalo's kind of just like stream
of conscious you know there's this
constant sort of thoughts coming out and
without having checked them prior
it's uh
which is yeah which can be uh
as enjoyable and fun as you'd imagine
if you had the powers of any of the
avengers who would you choose and why um
whose ability i choose maybe maybe the
incredible hulk because every time i was
i'd be out of line i could just blame it
on the other version of myself the
uncontrollable
version what's the most embarrassing
thing that's happened to you on set
embarrassing as it's just more
ridiculous is dealing with the costume
and the cape flying over the top of my
head in amongst
some sort of heroic entrance or landing
or fight scene and just
looking anything but heroic and we've
had to kind of cut the cape down a
little bit and have shorter versions
that we then
digitally have to replace later and um
so i mean walking around with the
the cropped version of the cape probably
looks
just as
silly
i'd love to see that in the next
interview i'll wear it
have you stolen any props from the sets
of your movies
[Music]
yep
um i have i have a hammer from just
about every film i think and then i took
stormbreaker from
one of the avengers films and this last
one
um
and they're all scattered around the
house in various places they often end
up in the
in the toilet and they're in the
bathroom my wife kind of
puts them there they i put them on the
mantel piece and she's like nah they go
in the back room
what's your best party trick
uh probably disappearing i'm pretty good
at kind of when i you want to get out of
there saying uh
you want a beer you want to vodka soda
tequila cool back in a second and then
out the back door at home
how heavy is thor's hammer
there's a few different versions of the
hammer uh the
there's the the sort of walk and talk
one which is quite weighty um but then
the stunt hammer is is is a lot lighter
and malleable in case it sort of clocks
me or somebody else in the head
unintentionally you know sometimes you
kind of you have the light one to be
swinging it around and it just looks
like you're swinging around something
that has no sort of weight to it so we
have to up it a little bit but then you
get the really heavy one and you sort of
throw your shoulder out and so
it's a it's a balance
which of the avenger actors would make
the worst superhero in real life
it's a wildly offensive question to
whoever i
uh peg with that one
um
oh i don't know uh
me
[Laughter]
they're all dear friends of mine i'd be
you know
yeah they won't be friends if i answered
that probably what's the closest you've
come to being injured on set all the
time um
i mean i have
i've acquired um
a lot of injuries over the years
your back knees to shoulders everything
um
often to kind of doing fight scenes and
punching things that aren't there and
you know hyper-extending shoulders and
you know kicks and legs and so on it's
pretty brutal um but i'd say that my
back's taking a beating over the years
just from the heavy costumes
um and then you're standing around on
set you're not warmed up and then all of
a sudden action you go from naught to
100 and
you know you're ratcheted across across
a
wall you're doing a fall or a fight or
whatever and
yeah it's a lot of weight bearing down
on
on your spine
if you weren't an actor what would you
be doing
when i was growing up i
i kind of had a different idea every
week of what i wanted to be and do and
then that led me to
wanting to you know
enter this business just because it was
um
i had trouble kind of focusing on one
thing i had a lot of different interests
and a lot of things so one week i'd be
like i'm gonna be you know go to the
olympics and you know
or play professional football or you
know be a doctor or be a police officer
or i'll be a lawyer or something you
know and it was just like things i'd
seen in films basically that i thought
oh that's cool so now i pretend to do
all those things
and uh and it's even more fun
do you think you've got the most
dedicated fan base
feels that way yeah yeah the star trek
fans might have something to say about
that
and marvel as well of course
yeah well
[Music]
you